lluvia de estrellas espera para la
primera alfombra roja de esta tarde
durante la competencia oficial de este
festival de cannes porque se presenta
wes anderson el director estadounidense
con su última película del despacho
francés que habla la historia de la
corresponsalía en francia de un ficticio
periódico de los eeuu y entre los
actores de ese nutrido elenco están por
ejemplo benicio del toro
owen wilson léase du o francés mcdormand
sino en la segunda película en
competencia regresa también un conocido
de cannes
kiril serebrenik o el director ruso pero
decimos metafóricamente que regresa pues
desde el año 2018 está en detención
domiciliaria recordemos que ese año
presentó justamente aquí en cannes
leto y no estuvo presente una detención
que su entorno considera arbitraria y si
no regresa también a cannes fuera de
competencia el director estadounidense
oliver stone con un documental jfk
revisitado que según él entregará más
información sobre el misterioso
asesinato del ex presidente
estadounidense 30 años después de su
película jfk